ce que je veux et qui me paraît fou
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on puisse revenir
sur un acquis qui me semblait essentiel
des lendemains la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est pas est ce que vaut mieux
d'économique ou le social c'était l'idée
que les deux devaient tenir ensemble et
c'est à dire que faire la prospérité
économique sur la misère sociale n'était
pas possible ça c'est quelque chose qui
me paraît absolument essentiel à garder
à l'esprit
alors bien sûr alors si on voulait
convoquer l'histoire parce que vous
évoquez l'histoire marx lui même disait
qu effectivement le capitalisme ne
volait pas il exploiter ce qui n'est pas
la même chose puisque effectivement il
dégageait de la plus value et qu'est ce
que c'était la plus value c'est la
différence entre le travail que le
capitaine n'ouvriers fait et le
surtravail stay en fait ils travaillent
plus qui nécessaire que pour sa
reproduction du travailleur comme on
disait
et que cette plus value est récupéré par
le capitaliste c'est ce que disait très
bien l'économiste a-rod il disait le
capitaliste gagne ce qu'ils dépensent et
l'ouvrier dépend ce qu'il gagne c'est
c'est une formule qui est qui
remarquable parce qu'effectivement ça
veut dire bien ce que ça veut dire c'est
à dire qu'ils achètent de la force de
travail il achète de l'outillage ça lui
rapporte quelque chose et il donne un
ouvrier qui lui ne peut que dépenser ce
qu'ils gagnent donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que en tant que tel on peut
concilier les deux c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il s'agit pas d'être
tout le monde à égalité à na li piette
c'est une très bonne formule pour
indiquer un petit peu la logique à
l'oeuvre dans les trente glorieuses
c'était la métaphore de l'escalator
c'est à dire ils disaient que tout le
monde se trouve qu'on nous serve
quelqu'un sur un escalator tout le monde
montrent certains sont en balles
d'autres en haut mais tout le monde est
emporté par le même mouvement vers le
haut et bien ce qui explique que un
ouvrier pouvait espérer dans sa vie
active rejointes progressivement le
niveau d'un cadre aujourd'hui les écarts
maintenant pour pouvoir rattraper niveau
de vie local sont parfois de 150 ans
donc ce qui devient de plus en plus
compliqué le cas en france 6 et si c'est
le cas en france génération voilà mais
il existe d'autres pays numéro 10 est
beaucoup moins donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est à dire que les états unis
qu'on a souvent présenté comme un pays
ultra libérale on a oublié cette phase
où ils ont utilisé beaucoup plus que
nous l'impôt sur le revenu l'impôt
progressif
l'impôt progressif pour pouvoir réduire
les inégalités
[Musique]